[Musique]
mathieu heures mathieu sk une ville
j'imagine que vous avez beaucoup voyagé
vous à quelqu'un qu'elle ai vu plein de
trucs incroyables
vous avez une ville qui vous plairait
alors dites pas las vegas parce que ben
tout le monde sait vous aimez las vegas
objectif repérer oui souvent limoges
n'ont pas pu les gens qui vous regardent
vous avez des fans en france n'a pas
seulement touché alors où ça et c'est
pas parce que l'émission n'est pas
connue internationale que je ne suis pas
connu atteint alors c'est quoi
il faut juste à bien les vielles allez-y
c'est que tu l'as vu le coût des ventes
est new york pardon new york
ah ouais donc vous aimeriez à new york
ouais ça c'est ouf c'est quand même un
truc comme ça allait à votre visage
humain sur broadway comment s'appelle la
place d'ailleurs où il ya tous les
rayons même square
j'adorerais voir là-bas à times square
ce serait cool non vous aimeriez vous
voir à times square moi j'aimerais bien
ouais jimmy fallon tout ça donne
peut-être dans une deuxième partie de
caresser quoi je pense que ce soir on
est capable de s'assurer que tous les
producteurs
vous retrouverez times square mais non
cyril que ouais bien je crois qu'il ya
un duplex ont fait exactement
gilles brisson nous attendent et on a un
duplex avec new york
non mais c'est mathieu to time square
tout new york
tous les producteurs tous les
producteurs vont vous voir mathieu
mathieu way we cas suspects ils savent
qu'ils appellent le prime
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rappel pas sachez que tous les
producteurs vont pouvoir vous joindre on
a parlé de new york
vous avez des tams colère je vous jure
que s'était pas préparé enfin que le
saviez pas qu'il admire times square non
mais on a prévu le duplex ouais on a
prévu le duplex qu'on était sûr vous
alliez dire ça mais c'est à dire que
vous saviez que lui allaient penser à
lui que lui en si bon joueur qui
aimerait un croyez pas ce que avait avec
ce que ça nous a coûté je peux vous dire
au président mathieu les producteurs
vont pouvoir vous appelez à tous au
pouvoir vous contacter regardez on va on
a duplex avec tam scolaire je vous jure
que c'est pas du pipeau regardez times
square là c'est à new york
est ce qu'ils en pensent et s'il vous
plaît benjamin j'ai bien regardé regard
des actifs de matthieu delormeau
là
tous les faits mais cette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars je vous jure que tout ce que
vous avez vu c'était vraiment à times
square série c'est vrai c'est que du
vrai visage et l'arrêt l'arrêt et amaya
benjamin il ya des gens qui l'appelle en
direct le pot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à nouveau sa bouche coulait regarder les
séries les ché j'espère que moi j'avais
à parvenir dans l'émission je vais aller
lui parler je vais aller lui parler je
vous jure que c'est vrai je vais
vraiment lui dire les choses elle est
énorme énorme je coupe un centre dans
les petits un dernier petit regard est
vrai que là c'est